Tonight, exactly
one week before the Georgia Senate
runoff election, Republican candidate
Herschel Walker is on defense again
this time
about whether he legally resides
in the state of Georgia.
CNN's Kay filed reporting tonigh
that Walker himself earlier this
said, quote, I live in Texas.
And he also said this in Washing
I'm sitting in my home in Texas
and I will
see what's going on in this coun
But during a campaign rally
just hours
ago, Walker claimed
that he's always been a Georgia
I represent the great people of
I've lived here my whole life.
Walker has been under fire
over this already
fending off questions
about his residency
after CNN's case
file reported
that Walker was getting a Texas
tax break
intended for a primary residence
OUTFRONT now,
Chris Cillizza, CNN politics
reporter and editor
at large, for more on this.
Chris,
this is not clearly the first co
that Herschel Walker
has been dealing with
since launching his campaign for
This is a new problem, this new
How does it stack up
against all of the others?
Well, let me let me first say
Kate, that clip
you paid where Herschel Walker
says, I lived in Georgia
my whole life is just not true.
I mean, he lived in Texas.
He moved to Georgia
to run for the Senate, which is
But just to do a little bit of a
check there.
So I have two contradictory thou
how big an issue it is on the on
As you mentioned,
Walker has been through a lot in
of allegations
about paying for
abortions, which he denied.
The campaign has
been hit
with a lot throughout the campai
and he's still standing right in
There's value in that,
politically speaking.
On the other hand,
we are seven days away from the
and this is a very close race.
So when you talk about those thi
Herschel Walker
would rather
not be talking about his residen
tonight and tomorrow
on the campaign trail.
So little things
can make a big difference
when we're talking about
a really close race
with really tight margin.
Yeah.
I mean, look,
accusations of carpetbagging are
and true political move over.
Ever since politics began
from Bobby Kennedy to Hillary Cl
Scott Brown, Mitt Romney.
Mehmet Oz very recently.
The resulting impact,
though, on their success
or failure in campaigning
and running is a bit mixed.
If you really look at it these d
Do these kind of attacks, do you
Do they have impact? Do they mat
So I think the key is authentici
Do you come off as authentic? Ri
Generally speaking,
and I think in some ways
where you're from
and how you talk about
where you're from matters there.
Let me take two examples.
One, Hillary Clinton,
who won, she went on, if you rem
almost before
she announced her candidacy.
But right when she did
announce her candidacy,
she went on a long
tour of every county of New York
essentially as a way to combat
the idea that she was just flyin
She from New York City,
and she wanted to be elected
The other extreme just happened
that he was
never able to prove
that he was authentically
from Pennsylvania.
John Fetterman
campaign did a really good job
of making it seem as though,
as was a New Jersey guy
who just happened to be in Penns
because there was an open
Senate seat
in Pennsylvania so often
Christie is always the key
in these campaigns,
and that's when carpetbagging ca
Interesting. It's good to see yo
Thanks for coming in. Good to se